I think I've always been a little low on iron. Some say those with a Mediterranean DNA run
that way. Supposedly, it is a genetic adaptation to prevent against malaria. Yes, that is true.
Remember, the labs that you're running are... You've got to look at your normal. It's like just
because normal temperature for a person is 98.6. Maybe your normal is 95.6. So you've got a fever for
you would be 98. So you have to look at what's normal for you. So the only way you know that is if
you took your temperature multiple times throughout your history and you know that that's what your
normal is. Same thing with blood tests. If you have a history of CBC prior to be ill, then you know
what your normal is. So then you compare that change with what is your normal. So that's the best way
to do it. So if you have a graph, because that's what you're really looking for, blood work, is
you're looking for changes. Of course, if you're drastically out of normal, it's always normal to have
white cholesterol. It's always 600. Well, no, that's not great. So there's within reason.